Hey, George, good afternoon.
How are you?
I'm doing great, thanks for asking. How about you?
Good, good.
Hey, Aman, thanks for joining in.
Good afternoon, Roberts.
Hey, George. Hi. Good afternoon. How are you doing? Good, good. Good to see you.
How's it going?
Good, good.
Alright, how's how's everything going?
Going good. Keep them busy, not too bad.
Yeah, so any changes that made on the auto task side?
No, we haven't. I haven't done anything on that. I need to get the I need to get those invoice the invoicing done out of there.
Okay, I'm not sure when this morning I was trying to pull the data for both, but it was not letting me to pull the data.
So, is something wrong with my credential or yeah?
I think we have few things probably because I was not able to pull the data for Noel and Saguna about their utilization, but I'll just check with you how they're doing, you know, and Saguna is still aligned, but how both are doing.
Yeah, I think everything's going good. Sorry, I was going to log in and make sure your license didn't change. Yeah, all's going good.
Yeah.
You know, we stopped going on site for that one client, so that had a financial impact, but I think we've been...
I think the ticket count has been about the same, doing pretty good, so not a large change there.
So, status quo is what I would say.
Okay.
Yeah, I get to hear that. Yeah, so yeah, I already connected with Saguna yesterday, right? Just kind of give him update so that we don't get surprised end of the month, right? So, so he's pretty good and we're looking a new opportunity for him, so he has been already aligned with.
the other partner to if he probably get the interview kind of process. So after 30th, he'll probably align with the different partner. So he is pretty good on that side. Yeah, he really don't want to leave. Yeah, he's really enjoying the work and everything, right? So, but yeah, that's how it goes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, unfortunately, that's, it sucks because it's not because of performance, you know.
Nah.
Because that way he was fully established everything, you know, know your clients, everything, no other extra support that he needed, you know, you know, the infra clients and everything would need to be done, yeah.
Who?
Yeah.
But you know, that's how the business goes, so when he's aligned with that. And I think another piece about the product scope that I shared with you, right? So I know you have little queries on that side, so do you think that what need to be?
And.
Yes.
Or maybe you want to make changes, maybe in the current one that I shared with you and kind of remove what is not required and what you needed and not right now, but yeah, whenever you get a time. So maybe just added the same quotation and.
So.
the task list that I have there.
Because I have the only one point, so just based on the conversation that I have with Noel, he gathered that information.
Yeah.
Um...
Yeah, well, why am I struggling to find this again?
I see your email. Oh, because it came from Natalie. Okay.
Yeah, and Natalie shared that.
And call this.
Yeah, I think.
So they don't currently have any...
Where's the scope? That's just for the signature.
That requirement came from client or does what you planned for them?
Oh.
Say, say that again.
So the scope of work that, you know, that you ask and that we have defined, that particular request came from the client, that that's what they're looking for or that's your recommendation to them.
So they don't really have anything right now. All of their users are local admins on their computers. And so we want to implement entry ID so that we just have a little bit more control. Can you resend me that scope of work? I have the, oh, never mind, found it. Just as I was asking.
Okay.
Got it.
I think one of the parts...
And like I said, it's small. It's only four computers and six users, something like that.
Um...
Actually requires them to migrate other computers. Oh, it says to remove dependencies on data RMM. Are you just meaning like more or less we would we would control the aspects of like lockout times and stuff like that from intro versus right? Because we don't want to pull data RMM off. Obviously, that's the RMM we use. Okay.
Yeah.
I'm reading that correctly now.
OK, and then...
Okay, so then yeah, so 15 hours from beginning to end.
Yes, that does look correct now, and then...
Let me look at her leg real quick.
So like 1800, 120 an hour. Okay.
All right, no confusion there anymore. I will, I'll build that quote and get that off to the client.
And then I can hopefully get a signature and we'll get moving on it.
Yeah, sure. And if you kind of just make a little bit adjustment on that side, then give a kind of copy to the client. That's what our plan. So if they have any suggestion that need to make any changes or anything with their recommendation, so you probably, you know, let me know. So I can add those or modify that. Because the way we, I know it's a very small project, but the way we do project like.
Okay.
Client share their requirement, everything, then you and but been involved, right? So we have a kickoff call with the client, understand what they're looking for, share our suggestion and everything, the scope of work with them and they review it. So once we have yes from the client, there is no confusion later on. Because what happens sometime, we implement something, client, oh, I never say.
yes for this, why you implemented this. So to just avoid that confusion, if we get the final approval from the client, the task list, oh yeah, we're okay to proceed with that, then yeah, we'll work on those.
Okay, yeah, I'll pull some of the wording out of your scope of work so they have a good basis and idea and then at the kickoff meeting we can make any adjustments.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I think the...
Another piece that I have for the auto task that we completed last time. So what is left on that side? I think looking some additionally build on that side.
Yeah.
Yeah, so you got so you actually you did you put in the
You put in the chart of accounts and then what I need is I need the
Yeah.
Trying to remember what they call there, the...
Two 7.
I think it was for...
like the product, the service bundles. So we need to build out the service bundles, and then I need to, I have two systems that are running contracts, and I need to move out of those systems and start putting them into Autotask.
Rochat.
Okay, yeah, I think yeah, my credentials started working now. I think I mean what happened this morning. I was able to learn, I think the MFA was, yeah, I yeah, I'm good to go to get the access to that. Yeah, I can review that because now I have the access and can log into the other task and share the.
Haha.
Yeah, no problem.
the finding. And I have your old email as well. So I think another thing probably happened, again, that was about, I'm not able to show you the numbers, yeah, due to the access, but the number and the utilization was they are doing, I know a lot of things that they do offline, right, not client facing.
Okay.
Noel specially work on it, and again, Saguna is going to upboard, so automatically Noel workload is going to increase whatever the portion of work Saguna was doing, right? He's gonna transfer to Noel, so he's aligned, right? So anything that, and he's, you know, ready to take new challenges, anything that you think he can take care, not just limited.
Yeah.
Okay.
what he's doing currently. So he's open to take it. Yeah.
I think we're going to, yeah, I think we're going to start getting into a little bit more of Untra ID, a little bit more of the security stack. So there's the new, there's the new email filtration, inky, another Kaseya product, shocker. So
Yeah.
Nikki will start implementing. And then I've got a guy, Dave, well, you know Dave. Dave's going to start reviewing all the accounts and making sure that we have all the right products in place. So Noel can probably expect to get some experience in implementation of the tool stack.
Yeah, Reid.
Yeah, definitely. I mean, again, I'm here to support him. So it's not that he is not getting support. If he's stuck anywhere, the first point of contact is me, where I help him to guide how he can proceed further. So I have involved him just kind of personally on the project side. So that way, if he need any end user support, anything, so he's aware of what's going on the back end, how we are implementing things.
So that will help him to on the front end side as well.
Perfect.
Excellent, excellent.
Yeah, I think that's only in my list. Yeah, so I'll get the auto-tasking check for you, right? And the other piece you can check at your end. Do let me know. Then maybe once everything is aligned, we can kind of have a kickoff call, right? And check the timing, et cetera, what client is expecting, how soon they need to complete.
That kind of timeline, so then we can proceed further with that.
Perfect. Sounds good.
And how about how about your the AI bill? It's the other thing service probably the best first.
Well, I haven't done anything. Things have been even slow. I'm just struggling. I'm trying to beat the cash flow, the cash flow hurdle right now. And then once I'm able to do that, then I can start getting back into it.
Yeah, definitely. A lot of things going around. So a lot of things we are building for the client partners in automation stuff. So yeah, probably going to really love those all.
I just lost audio.
Yeah, definitely let us know if you find anything. Yeah, we can hear you.
Can you guys hear me?
Yes, we can.
Oh, I can't hear you guys. Darn it. Hang on.
We can hear you clearly. How about now? Or would you like to...
Okay, I think, can you hear us now?
How about now?
Yep, that's now.
Thakur.
Okay, sometimes Team act like weird, so...
Leah.
Let's blame it on Microsoft.
No worries, right?
Yeah.
That's right. Yeah, so I think I was saying that, yeah, let us know if you have any future plan or anything right. The rest we're already available on team. If you find anything that immediate support help you need from our side, yeah, I'm always here to support.
Perfect. All right.
So there are a few things, George, which I definitely need to confirm. So first, I'll be sending you the link for our quarterly NPS survey. That is, let's say, how you would like to rate our overall services, Aman, me, Amit, Noyal, Saguna, overall services as a whole. That's for quarter one.
I have sent you the link so you can rate us. Nine and 10 are promoters if you would like to refer us to any of your friends. So that's one thing. Second is our monthly CSAT survey that's required for the scorecard for Sunny and Noyal both. So in case you would have already received the email on 4th of May, it would say monthly feedback.
For Saguna and Noel, if not, Aman, if we can send it once again and bring it on top of George inbox.
The main thing though, I know George, where you are coming from with the client going with the cash flow and everything, plenty of things which you are trying to bring back into place. But this is one thing which I'll definitely want to invite you. That's our annual build it live event. Let me bring it up on the screen. I'll send you the link.
This is a place to grow the network and around 550 plus MSP partners would be there. So this is our annual event. This time we are, it's happening on August 3rd to August 5th. That's New Jersey, Hyatt Regency. That's all the details. I'll send you the link. And this time we are taking our partners to New York Stock.
stock exchange for the after hours. Prior to this, we were able to take our partners to NASA Space Center. We booked the MetLife Stadium, then Statue of Liberty.
Very cool.
And talking about the attendees, 70 plus channel influencers would be there, tools, templates, processes, 0 sales pitches would be there. And then right now the focus is primarily all the MSP partners are more trying to monetize the AI initiative. So that's the focus for the three days.
On the last, on the third day, bring the agenda as well. So this is, we will have different booths available, different. So this is for August 5th, that specifically focused on AI accelerator program for our partners. Fourth, there will be breakout sessions for AI and future, for the leadership, for operations, for growth and sales.
And then for August 3rd, we will have the keynote speakers, John C. Maxwell, Dan Sullivan, everyone coming in. So that's a little bit about the event. The MSP ticket as of now, that's 1495. However, for our partners specifically, I'm putting you a code in the chat window for you.
That's 1 + 1 offer. So in case if you would like to bring someone else or your partner to the event, you can utilize this code and you can get yourself registered. And this is the speaker lineup because most of the MSP partners I mentioned, whether it's Strive, Red Helm, Hello PSA, MSP Corp, everyone will be joining into these events.
So any questions, any clarity required, what's in it for you?
No, I got the link so I will have a look at it.
Perfect. Rest in case if you would like to bring more people from your team, I'm just a text away so you can ping me over Teams. I'll see to it in case if there is a group coupon code where you can go, where you can give you some additional discounts. We would love to do so, so that you can be a part of this event.
Yeah.
I'm glad that things are moving as per your expectations and think of us as an extended part of your team, George. You don't have to wait for these service calls. If anything is going south, just let us know. We will love to connect with you and get it addressed right away.
Perfect, thank you.
Thank you so much for your time. Best you have a great weekend. Take care.
Great, thanks, George.
Thanks, guys. Take care.
Thank you. Take care. Bye.